one term that you're going to see
Wollstonecraft using quite a lot in this
vindication is the term education again
when we think of education from our
present-day vantage point most of the
time what we have in mind is some sort
of formal academic process the sort of
thing that happens in a school so you
know we we often distinguish between
education and training you know if you
go to a karate class it's not part of
your education and being trained in
karate if you go to pottery you know
whatever where you fire a pottery and
you know paint on it with the glazes and
put it in the kiln and do that sort of
thing we don't think of that yeah is
really education or we call that
continuing education because the idea of
the paradigm for education is pre-k or
you know that's that's if you're lucky
enough to have pre-k K through 12 and
then perhaps college or a vocational
school or something like that
Wollstonecraft means something much
broader by education namely any sort of
training the person providing them with
general ideas about how things work what
they ought to do where they fit into
society all of that is part of a broader
education and what it depends on she
talks about this in Chapter six is what
we call the association of ideas and
this is not an idea that she came up
with on her own it's something that's
kind of floating around out there at the
time there's other people talking about
this but she's saying that this plays a
very important role in how we understand
the relations between men and women and
their places in society so she talks
about you know the association of ideas
either being a ditch rule or
instantaneous and she says I'm more
interested in the [ __ ]
the things that happen over time because
of the repeated actions that we do or
the repeated situations or the
continuing institutions all that sort of
stuff and she says education supplies
you know the people of genius and that's
very rare with knowledge to get variety
and contrast but there's also a habitual
Association of ideas that grows with our
growth which has a great effect on the
moral character of mankind so she says
and by which a turn is given to the mind
that commonly remains through life so
the ways in which we come to understand
how we should look at people is a matter
of Education what we often call
prejudice is a issue of Education as
well so you know we can think about
prejudice and terms ethnicity or race we
can think about it in terms of you know
religion we can think about it in terms
of class you know sometimes people who
are raised in a an environment of great
you know privilege don't don't
understand what it's like for other
people and they may view them as their
natural inferior is that that's part of
what they're gaining from education in
this sense the association of ideas
you see people constantly being
mistreated you probably think well you
know maybe they have it coming to them
or that's what we ought to do it can
also take effect and it does according
to Wollstonecraft in terms of gender she
goes on and she says so ductile is the
understanding and yet so stubborn that
the associations which depend on
adventitious circumstances during the
period that the body arrived it takes to
arrive at maturity
can someone be disentangled by reason so
you know what's that you know boiled
down into more simple terms our
childhood screwed us up you know there's
all sorts of things where we drew the
wrong lesson from what we observed or
what somebody told us and if you know
once we get these ideas fixed in our
heads because of associating that way
it's hard to to get rid of them you know
this can extend the things as
says what kind of food you like because
you grew up with that it's harder to
make healthy food choices if your
parents don't don't feed you well
another great example that's a little
bit you know well it's not it's not
really innocent and the food choices
isn't either but you know one of the
best predictors for whether a child is
going to go on to become a person who
reads turns out to be not just whether
their parents read or read to them but
whether they actually see their parents
enjoying the act of reading reading on
their own not just reading out of a
sense of duty but reading because they
want to children who observe that sort
of thing
catch it but they don't catch it by you
know like the way we do with diseases
with organisms
it's rather through the association that
happens over and over and over again and
it becomes part of our character so she
says one idea calls up another it's old
associate and memory faithful to the
first impressions particularly when
intellectual powers are not employed to
cool our sensations retraces them with
mechanical exactness there's a kind of
mechanism a kind of automaticity
involved in this and you can see this
with people who have fears and they're
not quite sure where these fears are
coming from it turns out that maybe
somebody punished them at this time for
something associated with this or it's
just something just bad happened that
nobody had any control over and ideas
were associated so she calls this a
habitual slavery to first impressions
and she says it has a more painful
effect on the female than the male
character why because business and other
dry employments of the understanding
tend to deaden the feelings and break
associations that do violence to reason
so if you're if you're having to be in
the workplace and you're in a workplace
where if you don't do your job right
you're going to get fired you have to
rely on your Faculty of reason to some
degree and if you're a you know what we
call a hot mess because you know you've
got weird associations of ideas either
reason is going to break them or you're
not going to last in the workplace but
if you have an environment in which
things are a little bit more sheltered
and you can think about this with
you know the respect of the people who
enjoy certain privilege and they can be
quite sheltered as well there isn't that
impetus to deal with the the weird
things that associations have have done
to us
so she says everything that people see
or hear serves to fix impressions call
forth emotions and associate ideas she
calls this for women the cruel
Association of ideas which everything
conspires to twist into all their habits
of thinking or to speak with more
precision of feeling receives new force
when they start to act a little for
themselves
why because once a habit of mind and
action and emotion has been set like
that the person will tend to act in such
a way as to place themselves in
situations where it's going to get
reinforced they feel like they're
actually being free but they're actually
binding themselves even more to have it
through this force of Education so we
want to we want to pay close attention
to that now notice I've got the board
divided up into three things one is a
sort of critique of what's going on in
the education of women according to
Wollstonecraft
and we'll go into that in a bit of
detail and this is a cycle a vicious
cycle that goes in into society and
perpetuates itself and this is part of
what she's trying to break the cycle of
but first we want to look at this
education where does it actually happen
so she's got this great discussion about
several of these we talked about
Association of ideas already this can
happen through you know individuals and
their experiences they start to draw
conclusions usually we're drawing
conclusions from insufficient data so we
can you know get ourselves into all
sorts of models that way the remedy for
that is to have better information to
exercise our faculties
reason to become credit critical
thinkers as we call it to develop you
know some of the virtues that we need so
that's that's that's a possibility now
she says by individual education I'm
meaning for the sense of the word is not
precisely to find such an attention to a
child as will slowly sharpen the census
form the temper regulate the passions as
they begin to ferment and set the
understanding to work before the body
arrives at maturity now she also says to
prevent in a misconstruction I must and
I do not believe that a private
education can work the wonders which
some sanguine writers have attributed to
it what does she mean by a private
education there does she just mean
homeschooling no she would also include
what we call public education by that
the education where it's being done in a
sort of deliberate manner by people who
are supposed to be educators who are
supposed to be you know focusing on how
do we develop the child's mind all that
sort of stuff no you know how exactly
she would evaluate our current education
system that's an interesting question
which we can explore a little bit later
what about society itself doesn't
society teach us lessons a lot of times
people want to say all the media you
know that's what's to blame we got to
watch out for the music or the the video
games or the television or the
celebrities and that that's part of what
she's talking about there but it's also
the governmental institutions it's also
the general ways in which we think about
things that educates us she says men and
women must be educated in a great degree
by the opinions and the manners of the
society they live in we're were tempted
to think that were more independent in
our thinking of society than we really
are
we're actually influenced quite a bit by
our fellow creatures you know it takes a
lot just to go against prevailing public
opinion and to say no I believe this and
I'm going to hold to this belief very
often when people do it do that sort of
thing they do it in such a way that
actually screws them up another way is
just an obstinacy or
stubbornness or cantankerous Ness but
most people sort of get along to go
along and they do so in the realm of of
knowledge she says in every age there's
been a stream of popular opinion that is
carried all before it and given a family
character as it were to the century
isn't that an interesting phrase a
family character as it word of the
century what does she mean by that well
you don't think about how families are
families you know they may have tensions
within them and I know you know
teenagers are supposed to repel against
their parents but you know that that's a
recent thing a lot of teenagers don't
rebel against their parents and even the
ones that do rebel often you know by the
time that they're thirty forty they say
two things one is Wow mom and dad this
is if they were good parents mom and dad
actually knew what the hell they were
doing they were right about this that in
the other the other thing that they
often say whether the parents were good
parents or bad parents is Wow
I'm idea all right my mom I'm I'm saying
and doing the same sort of stuff that
they were doing at their age now I
understand how they felt why does it
happen well because these kind of
mindsets tend to replicate themselves
from generation to generation so when
she's talking about a family character
to the age what she means is that were
like one big family and we tend to
repeat the same ideas and opinions back
and forth to each other you can
associate this with cultures you know
for example in the United States we like
to get a lot of lip service to freedom
if we really look at things in a careful
way and we try to be consistent about
stuff we find out we have a month with
much less freedom than we think that we
do and we probably also have a lot less
of other things and we think that we do
but we give a lot of you know good talk
to freedom freedom is a good thing much
freedom as possible and you know where
do people tend to disagree well you know
that freedom is interfering with this
freedom over here so you know
right they have the you know freedom to
engage in economic Enterprise on the
left
maybe the freedom to you know get an
abortion or something like that right
freedom of speech on both sides unless
the other person is saying something and
when it comes down to it nobody's
actually saying well why is freedom a
good thing how do you know you've got
that right
there there are a few people who are
actually saying that but they're they
tend not to be in the mainstream there
are certain basic cultural assumptions
that are built into the you know the
mainstream society and it depends on the
era it depends on the culture depends to
a certain degree in class and things
like that but we we imbibed that we
learned that from the places that we we
live so she says it can be fairly
inferred unless society be differently
constituted much cannot be dependent
dependent that they expected from
education as long as you're not actually
changing the society and changing its
basic assumptions and a structures you
can educate however you like you can
tell here's a great example you know you
can tell every kid in your in your
civics class any one of you can be
president but you're really you know
making something up they're not all of
them could be president not in the
current you know situation that we have
first you got to like align yourself
with one of the two parties that's a
whole can of worms right there you got
to do a lot of selling of yourself and
sometimes even selling out of yourself
and you better not get a criminal record
any better you know do this you better
do that not everybody is gonna be up to
that and even if they did they're not
going to necessarily win most of us
can't run for president and that's
because of the way society is structured
so if you go and you tell your students
I believe in every one of you you know
society is going to tell them a
different message and society is
probably going to beat you the educator
do that so it's kind of pessimistic to
think about that's why are we doing what
we're doing here if that
okay now she also talks about the
importance of profession professional
classes and the professions that
individuals engage in are a lot of what
shapes their their mindset a lot of what
shapes their character you know if you
think about it work is where you do a
lot of your thinking and a lot of your
living in you know whatever setting you
happen to be in and if you're out of
work you know it's sitting around at
home which ends up being your way of
life or your job or maybe you do
volunteering but whatever it is that
you're committed to as a vocation that
shapes you that gives you certain
assumptions so you don't see the world
the same way as other people do she
she's very down on professional soldiers
she might not say the same thing about
military people in our day where things
are a bit different but the professional
soldiers in her time tend to be guys
that hung out in the barracks and got in
trouble around town and spent a lot of
their time drinking and dueling and
playing dice and playing cards and
talking up a storm and trying to seduce
the local women and you know in general
doing the sort of things that soldiers
that have done and they didn't develop
good character as a result she's even
you know more down on sailors because of
because of some other reasons won't go
into but you know you can figure out
anything on your own but whatever
profession we go into it's going to have
some effects on us the job or the career
demands a certain mindset from us if
we're actually going to be able to do it
so she will say you know the human
character has never been formed by the
employments of the individual or class
pursues and if the faculties are not
sharpened by necessity they must remain
obtuse now how does this apply to women
she's going to say also it's a great
importance to observe the character of
every man is in some degree formed by
his profession a man of sense may only
have a caste
countenance that wears off as he traces
individuality whereas the weak common
man has scarcely ever any character but
what belongs to the body at least all of
his opinions have been so steeped in the
VAT consecrated by authority that the
faint spirit which the grape of his own
vine yields cannot be distinguished the
idea is that some people become their
job they're unable to really think
outside of it
that's because education is happening
there it could be stultifying education
it could be ennobling education but
education is in fact taking place so if
you're stuck in some dead-end job you
know what we call a soul-crushing job
that could actually be bad for your mind
as well as bad for your your spirit and
your body according a Wollstonecraft how
do women stand with respect to
professions well she tells us something
here she says the argument may be
extended to women seldom occupied by
serious business as women who can
actually afford to be so the pursuit of
pleasure gives that insignificance E to
their character which renders the
Society of the great so insipid she
actually will draw a connection between
women who are confined to the domestic
sphere and men and women who belong to
the upper classes they don't develop and
her view a lot of character because they
don't have to they're not forced to and
they are poorly educated in this respect
as a result the only thing that she
points out is women for the most part
are stuck with just one profession being
what we call homemakers or the alternate
side of that is being marriage able you
know as they used to call it going to
college to get your Mrs degree well you
know what does that do that means that
they're not going to be involved in any
sort of profession which is going to
expand their minds and introduce them to
new ideas so their education is going to
suffer as a result
we're also educated very much by our
family life she has a lot of examples
here about what goes on within the
families where you know girls are
getting very definite messages about how
much they matter what sort of life is
expected of them how they can have
whatever degree of power or control that
they're gonna have namely through beauty
and attractiveness and manipulating men
there's a lot that's going on there and
a lot of these lessons are not coming
through explicit let me sit you down
here I'm gonna have a talk with you kind
of kind of lessons they're coming
through the examples set by the parents
the ways in which men and women interact
with each other within the matrix of the
family so if you've got a family in
which things are set up in a very
patriarchal way the man has all the
power you know whether it's Authority
spending power you know social power and
the woman has kept subservient that
woman's daughter is observing that are
going to come to see that as sort of a
natural condition to be looked for when
they end up you know marrying or perhaps
though they'll react against that if
there are a Wollstonecraft so what does
Wollstonecraft say she says the first
care of mothers our fathers who really
attend to the education of females
should be that they should take care of
their daughters minds and they should
also if not to strengthen the body at
least not destroy the Constitution by
mistaken notions of beauty and female
excellence this is something quite
interesting as well putting on makeup is
from wool stones a Wollstonecraft's
perspective a matter of Education when
do girls put on makeup what do they need
to do in order to be presentable you
know back in her time this included
using a lot of things that were pretty
detrimental to health but we still have
things like that going on today you know
think about the messages great example
here of a bad education that's very
detrimental to women more detrimental to
women than to men I know that there are
some men that that applies to but more
to women think about anorexia yeah
something that plagues our our society
particularly with with you know teenage
girls where are they getting the message
that they should starve themselves it's
not a natural thing to do you actually
have to go very you know strongly
against our natural urges that we have
as animals in order to do that well what
kind of images are they giving of women
in society there's been a lot of
discussion about this with models
you know models are in fact too skinny
and then they're Photoshop to make them
look even skinnier but they can be
getting this also from family life they
can be getting an undue emphasis you
know families that have eating disorders
tend to produce children who have other
eating disorders who pass them on to
their children you know when people have
these associations of ideas that they've
gotten through some sort of education
that end up causing them a lot of
travail and a lot of pain they they are
not so so you know they're not something
that just stays with them they get
passed on to the rest of the family
there's an education that takes place so
all of these are ways in which women are
getting educated
what else does Wollstonecraft tell us
about that what should an education
actually be like if women are being Mis
educated what kind of education should
they have by the way she thinks that
most men is educated in this respect to
education is very not just on like we
said you know information but also in
practical matters how we decide what's
good and bad whether we develop virtues
and vices how we should evaluate our
relationships how we should plan our
lives what prospects we should imagine
for ourselves how we visualize you know
where we're going to be 20 years from
now all that's a matter of
education so what should education do it
should exercise the intellect it should
develop our mental capacities this is
why traditional education has included
some of the subjects that it does
reading writing arithmetic and although
the 3 R's
write arithmetic mathematics
why do you mean those well if you want
to make it in this society particularly
in a society of the Internet you got to
be able to read and you got to be able
to write literacy is very important
numeracy is very important social
studies why do we have children do this
you know sort of vaguely defined field
of social studies which includes
everything from civics to history to
psychology because you want to
understand how human beings work and
what's been going on in the past and
where we might be going science why do
we have science education it expands the
mind it actually teaches you at least
something about chemistry and biology
and you know how to fuse these things
together in fields like earth science or
environmental science these kind of
hybrid fields as our world becomes more
and more and more technological the math
and science becomes more and more vital
to educate both men and women about
exercise their intellect
you know music exercises the intellect
artists exercises the intellect those
are not just you know mushy-gushy
you know fun and time kind of classes if
they're being done well they teach you
how to perceive color how to understand
how things come together in terms of
design music has a lot of mathematics
involved in in musical theory to learn
how to harmonize and what dissonance is
those are vital things education should
also strengthen the body
Wollstonecraft would probably be for
having phys ed classes so long as it's
not just teaching bullying but actually
teaching some you know some valuable
skills and strengthening the body she
also talks about the need to
from the heart and here she talks about
attaining virtue a genuine education
doesn't just provide us with information
it steers us towards becoming our better
selves towards realizing human nature
towards developing and understanding
traits like honesty justice temperance
or moderation gentleness these sorts of
things are supposed to be what a human
being ought to have and that is part of
what makes us independent this is really
central a genuine education in
Wollstonecraft's mind is supposed to
gear us towards a state of independence
it's not supposed to simply get us ready
for the workplace it's supposed to make
us people who can choose what kind of
job we're going to have and who might be
able to negotiate with an employer about
that sort of thing who also might be
able say this job isn't for me
now what happens what happens instead
women's education she says then again
she's she doesn't have in mind you know
what's going on in K through 12 she has
in mind what's going on in all these
other dimensions women's education
focuses on bodily accomplishments and
attributes it could be like you know
domestic things like learning how to
cook or sew but it also includes how to
make yourself attractive to men how to
be pleasing to the males oftentimes she
says it's not even good for the body
because of this undue emphasis on beauty
or attractiveness there's a lot of
sacrifices that get me she's got some
great examples of these I'm actually
gonna read some of this just straight
out because you know such wonderful
discussion she says you know throughout
the whole animal kingdom every young
creature requires almost continual
exercise the infancy of children should
be passed and harmless Gamble's that
exercise the feed enhance without
requiring very minut direction from the
head or the constant
tension of a nurse in fact the care
necessary for self-preservation is the
first natural exercise of the
understanding kids should be allowed to
run and play and you know fall down and
get themselves up and dust themselves
off because that's how they learn that's
how they actually exercise the intellect
that's how they learn not to screw the
screw up in that way not to be precious
little snowflakes that are gonna get
broken on every little you know rough
edge she says these wise designs of
nature are counteracted by a mistake and
fineness of lines heal the child she
means the female child is not left a
moment to its own direction and thus
render dependent dependence is called
natural so to preserve net personal
beauty the limbs and faculties are
cramped with worse than Chinese bands
well the boys frolic in the open air the
girls have to sit inside the girls play
with dolls why because they're stuck
with them because that's the toy is that
they've got and they're bored out of
their minds they're stuck hanging out
with their their moms you know a girl
condemned to sit for hours together
listening to the idle chat of weak
nurses or to a 10-minute or mother's
toilet the 10 that her brothers toilet
means sit there while her mom is putting
on her face while she's getting herself
ready imagine a life spent like that
what sort of education are you getting
you're getting an education that has to
do with just being charming with the
body not really enhancing the mind at
all so she goes on yeah and she says
that women are everywhere in this
deplorable state in order to preserve
their innocence as ignorances current
courteously termed truth is in from them
they're made to assume an artificial
character before their faculties have
acquired any strength taught from
infancy that beauty is woman's sceptre
the mind shapes itself to the body
roaming around its gilt cage only seeks
to adorn its prison men of
various employments and pursuits which
engage their attention and give a
character to the opening mind women
confined to one one profession taking
care of the desires of men having their
thoughts constantly directed to the most
insignificant part of themselves just
their body saw them extend their views
beyond the triumph of the hour this is a
major problem so she says you know that
teaches women just to focus on pleasing
men keeps them in a condition of
dependency they're not being educated
for anything better than that
if the only way that they can maintain
themselves is by getting somebody else
to like them to think they're pretty to
think that they're valuable for that
extent that only extends to providing
them the security of a dependent
relationship it also introduces rivalry
between women that doesn't need to be
there women see each other as
competitors within that field when they
don't need to be and so what does it do
it keeps women from developing virtue or
developing reason and here we get
self-fulfilling cycle it's almost like a
self-fulfilling prophecy
men keep women in a position where
they're going to be miss educated where
they're not see in the workplace
where they could learn you know more you
know particularly if they're in the
workplace they're not being allowed to
get into better positions they're
learning a lot of mores from society
from the culture and in family life you
know men aren't allowing the women to do
very much there so women become miss
educated what's the natural consequence
of that man thinking since they haven't
developed their intellectual capacities
because they weren't allowed to bad
actions desires and passions that you
know make them seem flighty
make them seem trivial make them seem
perhaps dangerous and needing to be kept
under
some sort of control but that's a
natural consequence of mis-education and
then what a man do men draw the
conclusion well women must be incapable
they must not be able to develop virtue
there must be something wrong with them
maybe they're lesser than men they have
less capacities revert you or for
intellectual development so what are we
going to do them we'll just keep the
current system in place and why bother
throwing away good time educating women
that obviously aren't going to do
anything with it
let's keep miss educating them let's
keep the current system in place and
notice that Wollstonecraft is saying
even the good guys even guys like
Rousseau who are all about the rights of
human beings are really only about the
rights of one half of the human race
about the rights of men not about the
rights of women this is why this is a
vindication of the rights of women one
of the most fundamental rights is to a
decent education